à new carlisle
il y a le boulevard gérarld lévesque en
l'honneur de l'ancien député de
bonaventure
il y a aussi la rue rené-lévesque
tournée descendez jusqu'à l'arrêt stop
au coin au 16 de la rue de monde sorel
vous trouverez la maison d'enfance de
rené lévesque
elle est belle de loin mais la maison
est quasiment abandonné et sont
propriétaires refusent de la vendre le
gouvernement pourrait même l'exproprier
longtemps lassés d'attendre la fondation
de la maison rené lévesque a décidé de
renoncer à l'acheter en lieu et place
tout près de là la fondation réalise un
projet beaucoup plus vaste
l'espace rené lévesque il y aura un
pavillon d'accueil tout neuf et surtout
à l'arrière on aménage un grand terrain
avec vue sur la baie des chaleurs
un espace où sera relaté la vie de rené
lévesque il y aura un circuit en huit
étapes avec des panneaux d'information
soutenu par un audioguide d'une heure et
demie tout le tempérament de l'homme qui
sera semble déjà présent dans ce petit
bonhomme de 6 ans le grand espace sur
rené lévesque n'aurait jamais pu être
aménagé autour de la maison
rené-lévesque dans un quartier
résidentiel en retrait mais moi je vous
dirais que je suis beaucoup plus à
l'aise de présenter un produit un lieu
de mémoire comme ça parce qu'une maison
natale
vous savez que c'est fille tout petit il
ya des étages l'accessibilité aux
personnes handicapées t on y prie avec
un conte n'a alors qu'ici on ne bâtit un
tout avec le contenu en tête et le
conteneur s'est organisée autour du
contenu
à une heure de là se trouve le chef lieu
informel de la fondation de la maison
rené-lévesque ceux qui la dirigent
un couple de médecins à la retraite qui
ont fait carrière à québec
l'équipe de la fondation a réussi à
recueillir 2 millions pour financer le
projet d' espace rené lévesque
ottawa québec et de multiples donateurs
ont contribué dont hydro québec quebecor
et power corporation
certains auraient préféré que le lieu à
la mémoire de rené lévesque soit aménagé
dans une grande ville plutôt qu'à new
carlisle ont trouvé que tout faire
gagner c'était pas vraiment intéressant
mais il si on se définir et quelques
repris pourquoi faire un esprit mais
c'est important pour le développement
la gaspésie c'est important pour
monsieur ne négocie pas il dit rené
lévesque qu'ils n'ont pas connu
personnellement mais dont ils sont
admiratifs
c'était un homme qui était d'une
intégrité exceptionnelle qui parlait
vrai qu'ils nous donnaient l'impression
de nous considérer chacun chaque citoyen
pour ce qu'il est et c'est dans cet
esprit qu'on avait dévoilé en 99 devant
l'assemblée nationale
une statue de rené lévesque sa conjointe
korine côté l'évêque avait demandé à ce
que la statue soit exactement de la même
grandeur que l'homme 5 pieds 5 pouces
pour montrer que rené lévesque était au
niveau du peuple et bien la statue a été
tellement au niveau du peuple qu'on
c'était digne et du comportement de
certains visiteurs
alors adieu statue grandeur d'homme
deux ans plus tard on la remplace par
une autre cette fois de 8 pieds 1 pouce
une statut semblable aux autres sur le
terrain une fois et demie la grandeur de
la personne représentée la stature
rejeté à québec
ray apparaît bien en vue devant l'espace
rené lévesque
alors rené paraissait minuscule et
pourtant c'est un homme d'exception un
homme d'envergure
mais là aussi nous qui l'avons suivre
est accessible dans le fond à new
carlisle puis à la gaspésie et à tous
les visiteurs
rené lévesque doit bien dans sa gaspésie